just attached all these amendments
that's why okay so
if i could start um there were four
bills that
had a lot of support the first was
senate bill 68
that's the governor's bill that senator
hennessey introduced for him upon
pregnancy i believe he retained it there
was no opposition
to the bill except for one
out of state attorney that just raised
some questions that were resolved
we had the executive director
of the human rights commission ms
malachi wrightville
it was caught up in house bill 1234 last
year so kind of vetoed
so it's been through the process twice
so there's no opposition twice
and we're a little bit perplexed as to
you know why
it got retained that's number one number
two
senate bill 69 um the breastfeeding bill
there's been a huge amount of work over
the years
on that bill uh consensus support again
no opposition
uh to that bill um clearly
both of these bills pregnancy bill and
the breastfeeding bill are very
important workforce bills
to make sure that people have you know
the opportunity
to work and you know whether it's
breastfeeding
pregnancy protection so that bill was
retained also and reflects that um
i'm going to let senator sherman speak
to senate bill 59 but i would just add
the
piece in uh i think it was senate bill
86 dealing with the atlanta conservation
issue for housing
again had broad support in the senate
it had been unfortunately the program
was appealed 10 years ago
this reinstitutes it but with no funding
um
at a time that affordable housing is
adds
in short supply many of us think that
that's an important though so we
um
absolutely really quick so one of the
things i like as an attorney is
the use of the word reasonable insist
and sufficient and again reasonable
so they're accommodating the employer
depends on what you have it isn't
we're not giving you a one-size-all
thing it's very adaptable
very flexible so i just like the
language in both section
uh 29 and 30. i'm sorry senator sherman
go ahead
no it's fine uh first of all i am
fully supportive of 68 and 69 i think
they're phenomenal bills i think they've
had strong bipartisan support
and and i agree completely
with karen bradley that
they are
[Music]
really critical for workforce especially
as we look at the impact on women
of coba has had a disproportional
impact on women we need to get them back
in the workforce
and especially with our unemployment
rate being
impressively low so
that being said those are my highest
priorities senate bill 59
passed the senate 24 to nothing we are
in the middle
of a mental health crisis
and senator bradley will attest to the
fact that we've been listening to the
carriers say we cover it already and
they don't that's fundamental here they
don't cover it
so this is the standard of practice in
psychiatric care the benefits to the
state
would be number one workforce we have
one of the most challenged psychiatric
workforces in the country
we cannot recruit and retain partially
because of our size
most of our psychiatrists come out of
the dartmouth program which is a
wonderful program
but this is critical not only for
ease of access for patients it's also
important for workforce in terms of
the availability of psychiatrists and it
ensures
that this model will get reimbursed and
as a doctor
over and over again i've heard from the
carriers that they cover it they don't
well this is
on all sorts of issues but on this one
that's what we've been told
and so at least five states have
instituted put it into statute so that
it would be important you know as well
as i can and we've been working for
years trying to make sure that
parity is part of the ten year mental
health plan
this dovetails perfectly with the mental
health plan dovetails perfectly with the
integrated delivery network which we've
it's been an
awful lot of federal dollars at least 50
million dollars that's closing up now
this is the model that we need i
understand
that they are saying that they cover
this shouldn't pass
for whatever reason this does not make
it through this process
then the next step for me will be to
make sure that we're documenting
any failure of coverage um
but again we're in the middle of a
crisis we don't have time to wait and
see if the carriers are going to cover
we've seen in other areas like er
boarding they don't cover it they say
they do and they don't
sp70 which we held on to in the senate
was an effort to make sure we hold them
accountable and
you know on all these bills
i think this is critical i think it's
important that we address the mental
health
issues i understand
the concerns of the chair um
and i would ask that we consider this
that's it i think this is a critical
part of our response to mental health
crisis
okay well we'll start with that one um
i mean we need the evidence that that
they're not coming
don't worry us to say they're the liars
so that they tell us that it's not true
so it must be in the evidence
so yeah i need to build a case
clearly you could put the bill in again
come back january
you know what and i would just say you
need to have some evidence
you need to have it i would i would hope
that
the insurance companies have heard this
and that they heard you and that they
will make sure that uh they are
government and that and to me that would
be
even more effective if we get them to
cover it without and i would be
100 agreement with that i i
i would love to see that happen
okay next uh we'll take the these two
uh so let me just if i could add i was
going to talk about that
59 yeah um
you know i think it's really important
i'm looking at the hero report of the
senate
we talk about evidence okay um
the support for the bill was
overwhelming from
you know folks in the field patrick hold
the new hampshire psychiatric society
michael patmore the medical society
um sabrina dunlap from anthem jake barry
new futures paul minnigan hospital
association
john dejoy national association
healthcare workers courtney tanner
who's here from dartmouth kim norton for
nami
um no opposition to the bill not zero
and i think that you know senator
sherman um
you know it's pretty well connected in
the medical fields or
what's actually happening so we were
kind of mystified
with the kind of support for a model
that has
no opposition having it in law makes it
clear that reimbursement for this model
of collaborative care which
allows more participation by
different health care workers at a time
that we know we have shortages
in particular of mental health workers
is pretty
important and so i think that the
you know the fact that folks that
we all listen to who i just cited um
had you know universal support from the
carriers
to the healthcare professionals i i just
again
it's mystifying why we didn't afford
them
yes i have to agree um you know 59 was
one that we did hear from both sides
um well there really was an opposition
to it and the fact that
um many of our patients are they see
their pcp and they have a
closer relationship with them than they
do with mental health um
professionals and if they can work
together
um what if medication is necessary if
counseling is necessary
and it keeps them from having to go to
another provider
which in some case in some cases would
prevent them from getting
further care so um you know certainly i
think
and and supported 59 and would like to
support 59 here
so um the issue really is that if it's
already
covered then why do we need it i would
agree with you
but we're you know certainly what we
have heard i think
senator sherman more than anybody else
because he is
in the field every day different
practice obviously
but uh really well connected people are
telling us
and you know as we'll probably
see senate bill 70 next session and keep
hearing things are covered but then we
keep hearing things
or not so um
i think we all know that we need to get
to the bottom of it
it'd be one thing if there was any
opposition to the building
there's not and and that's the fun
i mean i say there's no opposition no
because it's already law
it's not law it's already
policy of the insurance company from
but then we hear the
people aren't getting covered for this
model of care that there's no opposition
to the bomb
and it's already reimbursed for medicaid
and medicare
so again but i'm sure they don't have it
in the rules that that's just been
covered
so i'm saying is why why would we want
to think
i mean there's a lot of things out there
that you know you say these are you know
midday or things that are being covered
that we should have in the statute
we only put things in the statute is
when we actually
have evidence that companies are not
we're missing the big picture when we
sort of get into that kind of detail
whether it's in the statute or not we
believe it's not being covered
despite um some of the assurances you've
gotten
and there's no opposition to having it
in statute so whether it's in statute
and not being enforced or
or whether it's a practice but not being
enforced or being
reimbursed or whether patients have to
advocate for
individual care i think that's a problem
because there are many that will be able
to advocate for themselves
we you know we do have things in stature
unfortunately it's usually in psychiatry
we have parody builds in statute because
there was not
parody and in the senate hearing
we heard that yes as far as we know
anthem covers it we don't know that all
carriers
cover it we heard from heidi that it
should be covered and that's why they
were actually on board with it this sets
the standard of practice and psychiatry
i agree 100 we don't need to put
standard of sedation for colonoscopy in
the statute
it's covered it's done and
but in areas where we have deficiencies
where we also have a crisis
it actually is a role for statute and
we've done that
there is a precedent for it in
psychiatry in the parity
this is part of the ten year plan this
is part of
how we respond as a state to the fact
that we
still have people boarding in our
emergency room
obviously we have to uphold the house
position the house did vote on this
particular bill
right but with further evidence that i
think you've presented today
you know we've gone to the ends of the
earth
financing thank you for proceeding
on or concurring i mean on 143
you know a licensure bill hopefully the
secure
psychiatric hospital gets funded in the
budget i mean
you know so i just see no reason not to
move forward with this bill if it's just
you know to uphold the house position i
get it because i've been in your shoes
but i i hope that you can understand the
in the middle of a crisis where we're
trying to move
heaven and earth to get resources to
people that need
the resources for mental health
counseling and treatment
that you would reconsider
it's really important to use
show me the evidence tell me that the
insurance companies are not covering it
but show me the opposition to it and and
i will
the opposition is in in terms of
because that's a nitpick the
conversation that you're nitpicking us
in the middle of a crisis that when
there's no opposition to
a care model and it's important to have
it clear for reimbursement purposes
the fact that um you know
you're holding on to a position because
you voted it down
it just i understand the dynamic of it
but
it just seems in the middle of a crisis
there'd be a little bit more open
mindedness
okay all right my final government is
okay
when you say care model okay um
as uh but little i know about health
insurance
uh everything is driven about what are
the standards of care
okay and what then the sense of care
which is
generally accepted practices okay
um if you say four states
have done this now i think it's seven or
eight okay
so so the issue really is that in terms
of
what is going on in the nation why is
this the national state
if if the insurance companies are
telling us it is
and we have no particular reason not to
believe them unless you're going to find
evidence to show us where the refusals
and that it's cur occurring and that we
can't you know
can't correct it then i would say yes
then it's worth you know
then you need to put it but the idea of
putting in this model
legislation that's supposed to be the
standard of care that everybody
should be doing uh is a problem for me
because there would be a lot of that
stuff we would stick in the book so then
it just becomes
uh you know more more mandates that
nobody you know nobody reads or care or
evidently following or something i don't
know
so and our our attitude is right now is
that
this if we need you know show me
evidence that's not happening
okay let's go on to 68-69 okay
um the problem that the the committee
had with 687
and i'll have to be frank um uh my my
drums would have been that
uh we we didn't even have this sessions
you know we
just retained everything and and wait
till september
and have her session then but of course
that that was just my personal opinion
when it comes to a commerce committee
as you uh probably know we do a lot by
subcommittee we would do
every bill by something that every bill
would have another
opportunity to have a little discussion
before so that by the time we get to the
full committee we pretty much know where
we're going with it um i made a
commitment that we would not have any
subcommittees this year
because the idea of doing subcommittees
on the zoom session
just didn't seem right or workable
we like that free throw
communication that occurs so um the
reason we retained these bills were that
that their
committee members definitely had
questions and
they're some of the words were being
used legal words and things that that
you know a lot of people wanted to
make sure they understood the
consequences and understood it and then
the comment came out to that that the
human rights commission is actually
doing it already
so that they don't you know so why are
we passing a statute if they're already
doing it
that they already have the authority
that when we created the human rights
commission they have the authority to
internet
so when that piece finally came out that
was okay they threw up our hands and we
said
that let's just retain these two and and
work them through the sum come september
and hopefully
we'll have something you know to get out
of committee come
you know be on the floor next january i
think i have to take exception with some
of what
your recall is on that this chair um
we went through both of these bills um
previously and they were passed
um both on voice vote and then they were
lost the covet
only buses these haven't changed they've
been worked on
through both 68 and 69 have been worked
on over and again there's a
tremendous amount of support for them we
had um
huge numbers of the of testimony on both
of them and
the questions really came up from new
members of the committee that weren't
involved in all of the work we did in it
in the past
so i think you know both of these bills
are um
are ones that a tremendous amount of
work has but it's really important to
um as senator sherman was saying about
getting women back into the
workforce and feeling safe um that they
can be nursing or can be pregnant and um
there
there's accommodation in the bill that
if it
it's um a problem for the business
then they can give cause that
something they may not be able to comply
with um would still be considered
so i i certainly hope that we would uh
move forward
because the the sense in that in the
committee really was that
these these both of these bills have
have been worked on tremendously already
well i think you said it right now i
said we have new members on the
committee
things changed well they weren't able to
hear
um everything all at once um
you know having two
[Music]
so if i might we're sort of in the same
dilemma
on cynical 68 as you probably
are the underlying which we all support
and my understanding is that
that bill also got caught up in 1234
last year as did senate bill 68 or the
earlier version but
it was my lesson responsible for the
government
um i just think it'd be a darn shame to
you know not move forward with a bill
that had you know
broad support no opposition especially
once the out of state attorney had
you know the questions answered was
written by ms maliki
of the human rights commission
that we couldn't move forward with the
bill
because we're unable to have zoom sub
commission which again
that to me is it's i don't know
um i feel like we're in a samuel beckham
play waiting for godot
the same thing happens over and over
again um
on both the underlying bill and senate
bill 68
without a reasonable explanation as to
why we're not moving forward with it
because i think everybody would agree
at least i hope that the way the bill is
constructed that there should be
reasonable accommodations for pregnant
employees
i i don't i suspect there's no
opposition to that
there certainly wasn't in you know the
senate here
did you have a subcommittee on six times
we
no we haven't had any subcommittees so
how did it pass that these others
don't pass because there's no subjects
they're they're in the same bill
they're in the same book as you put in
no no they're in the same omnibus bill
last year that passed the house in the
senate six
ten you know terms you know you it was
an honest bill because you
put it into anonymous building okay so
that
that so anyway 610 uh is a
banking department bill it was a
standalone
and and so there was you know in terms
of it's not about the omnibus and
whether it's hacking it or not like that
it was that this issue
had been addressed it had been worked on
its issues
you started out as a study committee and
we had all
the issues resolved and things you know
that that was a couple years ago so
it's really a shame to have it die
because you guys put all these
non-demand amendments
on on a commerce bill that that that
is a housekeeping measure if i could
follow up
you just said that 6869
even though they previously passed the
house
in the same bill as 610.
had to have a subcommittee i don't know
they were equally vetted at 6 10.
uh no well the difference being
is that that we obviously did have a
change in
human alliance and we have an election
no i understand
elections unfortunately have
consequences that we had a lot of new
members
so when it came to 610 the banking bill
the new members had no problems
understanding and getting their arms
around
the issues when it came to 1669 the new
members
clearly were not ready so let me just
pass that
if i could just be absolutely crystal
clear from that medical standpoint from
the health care standpoint
a lactating or pregnant mother who does
not have a combination
cannot physically work in a place that
does not provide that combination
just want to be clear on that so we are
putting
the fact that members
are uncomfortable with pregnant or
lactating women
above a banking bill and we're saying
that's two different standards
and so with you're asking us to pass a
banking bill which i fully support
they are equally vetted and you're
saying that your committees
will at the very least delay
action on this for up to a year
because it would come back next session
you didn't put it in again well it's
retained these are both retained
right we're working on it so we'll have
it out in january
but if if we're if you weren't to be
happy with what we come up with
you have every opportunity to put in
your own bills but to say that we're
putting them
black tiny women above banking is no
you're putting them actually below them
so you have a lot of evidence that
employers are doing this
that then i'm telling you that 25 of
women
currently are unprotected by the federal
lactating bills because of the size of
the business
that's what this attempts to address 69.
so the question we had was the the only
time the only antidote story we ever got
was actually
the state agency and so so
i mean are you saying that a lot of
employers are not not
taking care of their employees why
wouldn't we
protect wouldn't we well something
because
we again statutes are for one another no
there's a problem
we should fix but we also how much how
much
evidence do you have that there's really
a problem up there that employers really
are not taking care of their employees
i'm not sure i follow mr chair i think
we do a lot of statute to protect people
proactively exactly to make sure that
they don't have
you know what you're asking women to do
is if they do have a problem
they have to go to uh the
governor's council or the uh
the state council so it goes back to
case by case this is proactive it says
no we as a legislature as a state we
respect the right of women
to have a medical condition known as
pregnancy
or a medical condition known as needing
to breastfeed my child
we respect that and we don't want them
to have to go and do
uh go through appeals but there's also a
process
i mean this is going forward this is to
prevent them from having to go to court
because
human rights commission is um has
experience with the issues with the
businesses they work as mediators
they've got the experience and this is
to put that into stature
and again no opposition from the
business community
they were on board like you said just
like my new members of
my committee were not prepared
i mean maybe the senate is prepared not
to
proceed to the banking that's your
choice
unfortunate because as you know senator
d'alessandro and i have led the
charge on updating our trust laws so i
mean
i don't like to be put in this position
but you're using process
to undermine protection for
pregnant women and breastfeeding women
and
i think you know i would suspect i speak
for all three of us and all 24 of us
that
that's not acceptable
why does the process make this process
69 again no opposition
it's been broadly vetted
so both chambers and we're here to help
the people of new hampshire
i mean that's part of our process and we
get criticized when this kind of
of an impasse comes and you're
making it really difficult for us to
meet needs that are there i think it's
weird that you guys are using the word
process
because we don't like in general we
don't like this process
this is the intent of this these bills
are really important to the women
of new hampshire and you want to stand
in the way no
women i i think most women are having
able to work it out with their employer
we don't there's not a there's not about
money it's not about
that
there's only one moment yet we've got
the story
mr chairman there are people shaking
their heads over here
women again actually when we get in that
subcommittee when we retain the bill
this september we'll get they'll need to
bring forward that evidence
the show is really problematic
it's usually you guys have the time you
have no time well i'm on hb2
so my time is pretty short too
okay i think this is important because
again
you're using process against protections
for
[Music]
you know pregnant women are
breastfeeding right
i can assure you that that uh yeah yes
you would be kissing the healing process
but that there was a majority of my
committee you know that was ready to
kill these girls
and i convince them that let's keep them
and work on
so you understand you're preaching to
the choir somewhat to me
when you're saying this you know we need
to you know we need to do this
and i'm saying is i i certainly am
sympathetic
it's not like this is the first time
i've seen these shoes um i think
it's probably it's commerce i think i've
had this three or four times
so i just uh it's okay isn't it time
i i can speak to some of the evidence so
the length
so the language of senegal 69 is the
result of three and a half years of an
uh advisory committee that was
established in previous legislation
that was passed and so we were charged
with coming up with language for this
and we did just what we were charged to
do in that council and it was to work
collaborating
collaboratively with stakeholders and we
did that and the evidence
is in new hampshire eight out of ten
moms initiate breastfeeding in the
hospital
that's incredible but only three of them
are still breastfeeding fully at six
months and we know
one of the barriers is returning to work
and so maybe
you don't hear about the stories but
that's because moms don't have time
to file a complaint their bill
will dry up in a couple days and so
they're done
and for many of them they need their
jobs so they have to choose their job
and so they keep working and then they
use an alternative sports computer
but it's unfortunate that they have to
make that decision
so we get calls i've worked at the
department of health
i'm a lactation consultant so if you
google breastfeeding health you will
find my name
and so i get the calls while it's not my
duty to
support them in their legal efforts for
returning to work we do offer them
education
and you know support and where to go to
get help and so
it's happening the calls come in
employers call me
hr staff help me what is appropriate
what do i need to do
we help them we have tool kits available
so
i realize maybe you're not hearing the
stories but for those of us
working in this field the last 10 20
years um the story's
hopefully we'll get through this in
september and october
take these bills out appreciate it our
moms need the protection
now yesterday
um what's the plan for the senate next
year with comedy plus
there's a lot of resistance building in
the house towards
bills that have lots of different
subjects in them it's kind of out of the
ordinary but
can we speak to the process next year
because it might
so let me just say this um you know
when the legislature reconvened in
december
we were facing 300 bills
24 members uncertain housing was going
to work
for all the processes we had all the
public hearings that we had to get
through
i regret that all of you
found that process offensive
but we were trying to protect our staff
utilize the best ability that we could
the technology
to get through the unprecedented
workload
that you had to get through we got
through it
um if we had had 300 bills
you would have even more problems than
you had with obviously
i think it's safe to say as a majority
leader
in the house that the pandemic's over
less blessings for that hopefully it
never
returns again and we never have to use
zoom
for the process again omnibus bills
would be a thing of the past
that's my hope that's my expectation
and then the other last one the
workforce housing one again
the house
commerce bill which gets to the idea
that
we're where the house has a problem
so again on this bill there was broad
support for it
in the hearing process yes it was an
omnibus build
as i vindicated to representative ammon
the
whole purpose of that was to be able to
conduct hearings
in an orderly fashion it was supported
by
the municipal association it was
supported by the association of
realtors
there was no opposition to the bill
once that was supported by housing
action new hampshire um
you know just a quote from melissa
martial who
chairs housing action new hampshire um
and represents ap organizations this was
a program that had been unfortunately
repealed
and i believe it was the 2011
budget we are
short some 20 000 housing units
it gives municipalities a better option
you know in how they deal with
conservation planning
zoning funding for it it just puts the
initiative back on the court
so i see that i believe
if someone from the school is here
so maybe you entertain a minute or two a
third time
man
hi everyone uh so
uh this bill senate bill 86 part two
originally was
it's basically the number one priority
of housing advocates this year as
senator bradley ultimately stated you
know we have a housing shortage of about
20 thousand units across the
state i think we all know that um
housing is
urgent in order for us to have our next
generation here to keep our economy
thriving
you know we need people to take over our
dental practices our accounting
practices our
civic boards you know everything that
keeps main street new hampshire
functioning depends on us
keeping up with housing and making sure
that young people are here so
this program is completely optional it's
something that municipalities can apply
for it's to support them
there's no budget asked for it this year
so it's really just the language backing
statute
has no impact on costs so
my hope is that given that it's
completely optional for our towns and
cities
and that um there's no fiscal impact
from it that this is something we can
just
put back into operation and in future
years then it's ready if
we're
and i know you want to have your
hearings and you want to have a process
so sometimes we run into in the court
system
things aren't working out the laws just
don't take care of what's so the court
looks to equity
to do the right thing sometimes you have
to put the process
aside and i just can't see especially in
29 and 30 those two sections the sp 6968
the equitable thing to do is just go
maybe we didn't
it's a it's an odd year we had a kobe d
or you couldn't get your hearings in but
they need the solution now
so could you not put the process aside
and err on the side of what's right for
women on these two
the bills are not dead no no they're not
tempted it would be another year
she needs the thing now that women are
calling now if they're not getting
their needs money i need to do the right
thing for the people
if it wasn't for cole but you would have
got your hearing said
so i would have had myself today you
would have yourself
so we couldn't do the process correct
members alone but just like report it
doesn't always have the
law on their side they can go to equity
and do the right thing so i'm asking you
to try to do the right thing and
maybe overlook the process
i think the women of new hampshire might
like to do that as well as the chair if
you don't act on this
this is not one year delay this is two
years away this was one of the last
years
you know i have to agree with my chair
that
we're holding up what is completely
in a critical part of our policy that we
make as legislators
because you couldn't have subcommittee
it's not that it's wrong it's not that
it's bad it's not that
if it needs to be fixed you can actually
come back and you can fix it next year
but yeah
right we'll figure out the right way
in the meantime it was because you were
and we can
you're in charge well and we can come
back and
change it if you need to change it but
right now the people of new hampshire
are asking us
to do it we've you know we've had lots
of testimony on it we've had
many people sign in as well there's
plenty of interest in this
and we are criticized when we don't
listen to the people
and this is these are two bills that we
can listen
to the people to be friendly and you
still want to bring us in the house they
can turn it off
i would say the first time i heard the
breast feeding issue
it's gotta be over 10 years ago so
there's been plenty of opportunity for
and and it took you
the democrats were in charge that they
could have gotten it passed yeah
but all i'm saying is that right now i
have a republican committee that
would very much like to spend a little
time to make sure that
they go through the words and ensure
that it
is in their minds um
it being fair to the businesses well i
don't think this is partisan although
you obviously do
i think this is about women this is
about equal rights for women
equity parity and by the way the time
frame was started several years ago i
believe it was by
a majority republican uh body where they
put in place the advisory council which
is where this came from
so let's be straight and honest with
each other
what's happening here is yet another
year of delay
as you said this has been going on for a
decade
what's one more year one more year is
equity denied for women
in new hampshire that's what it is it's
i
i would say fundamentally that is your
problem because when people when you say
equity and parody okay it's not
because men don't have this problem all
right and i
certainly respect the fact that we want
to treat women
but we have wives and we have spouses
and we have foreigners
so we do have this problem it may not be
in our own bodies
but that's one of the reasons
see how we can get to the right answer
here but if the house decides to
non-concur
they can make another decision but at
least we can bring it forward
no i i i'm not pulling the house
position
so if i can make a suggestion
why don't we reconvene tomorrow morning
you
have an opportunity to think about all
four of these bills
and come back to us hopefully you will
accede to some or all of them
we're we're i think we want to go back
to the university bill
as opposed to just saying no right now
i'm certainly willing to come back
uh you know i i just i i i'm not gonna
change my position so i don't know what
the purpose of coming back tomorrow
i'm not going to change my potential
because you would have a chance to talk
and your leadership
talk to members of your committee
i think all of the bills are ready to go
technically they're fine i don't think
they need any amendments on them
i think what we're hearing is this is a
process problem
and i think what we're trying to say is
we need protections for mental health
patients
and we need protections for pregnant or
breastfeeding women
and i think those all
should override the process issues
i mean we did the best we could with
omnibus bills
to ensure the process was smooth
you've had issues with zoom okay i get
that
but show me where there's a problem in
any of those three builds
i know i'm not as familiar i will admit
with the
atlanta conservation bill um i think uh
senator perkins boca did a good job of
defending it she was very articulate on
the floor
and we fully support but
and knowing how important affordable
housing is we ask your consideration on
that too
and you know we seem to be at an impasse
i don't like it in the past but
that's where we seem to be right
i'm going now ask my other members of
the committee do you guys
receive room here
there's another issue we're talking
about politically sensitive topics right
and it's uh those issues
are good to raise money for a campaign
in addition
yes i mean i acknowledge that
um but there's another position of not
micromanaging managing
to do the right thing that's that's
another position
where we're not we're not trying to
solve problems with mandates
but that you know having faith that
society to work
out these issues
either opposition or suggestions from
the business community about how to
you know either fix or approve or even
against
you know 68 69 and
uh 59 the fact of the matter is
we have no opposition not from the
business
i think that you know the protections
offered for mental health patients
and pregnant or breastfeeding
moms are pretty darn
important that's our message
so in the committee i took the business
side
and i played devil's advocate and i was
the one who kept saying
is this going to be an imposition on
businesses and they kept
assuring me and we went through every
little detail of sufficient reasonable
breaks so it depended on the size of the
business
and we left it as broad as possible to
accommodate the employers
and the employee so it sort of was
vetted already in the senate hearing
um i don't know if you read reports
but these ideas came up and we we are
not at all putting any restrictions on
businesses
everything was left to again i love
those words they were the legal words i
was looking for
reasonable and sufficient to accommodate
both the employer and the employee
and just think it's the time
place to do this
um i don't usually speak up too much
my problem with 68
and 69 is defining
visualness that bucket is so
big that i think it needs more work to
define that
reasonableness so the reason we did it
that way
so i brought up a pizza place and sand
down this because i was like this is
this is not good it's going to restrict
businesses too much i said what about my
little shop and they don't have any
separate rooms and stuff
and so they're going to be able to work
it out whatever works between them and
their employee and then if they have a
problem
they can go to the governor's commission
but we're giving
both sides the opportunity to try to
work things out first so we're not
putting the heavy-handed government in
first
we're letting the employer and the
employee try to work things out
and then if they can't decide what's
reasonable and again
one building's different than the next
so you can't have a one-size-fits-all
that's why we use those general words i
agree
but there's there is some more
wordsmithing that needs to be done
to ensure that every situation just like
you said
from the small mom-and-pop to the large
corporations
are covered correctly just that's
one term
doesn't make me warm and fuzzy
okay the housing and planning commission
are not against workforce i live in
derry
we got workforce housing londonderry
doesn't happen london doesn't have
salaries and
our school system is suffering from
climate care model i was one of the itos
[Music]
it was just not cold
it it is where medicine is going
in every aspect of gastroenterology i
started my practice
10 years ago at requested for physicians
the whole concept is collaborative care
it means that it's much easier for a
patient to get access
it means that it's less expensive
both on the system and for the carriers
and it means that one psychiatrist
or one gastroenterologist this isn't
about gastroenterologists outside
is able to see much larger patient
population
because of the type of interaction
they're having
so collaborative care
is a medical term it is a standard of
practice
in medicine it is not happening in
psychiatry the way it needs to
and that's part of the reason when you
look at our 10-10 year
mental health plan that's part of the
reason why
we don't have the services that we need
to keep people out of the hospital
on the front side that's possible i
understand about collaborative care i go
to dairy medical center
that's great extremely collaborative
care
so some mental health therapy doesn't
fix this problem
i think that senator whitley would like
to address this
argument yeah yeah thanks thank you so i
just wanted to
address the concerns that you all raised
because certainly we have
thought through those and um so i wasn't
sponsored this year but has been worked
on by many other senators
and certainly the senate committee put
us through her pieces to talk about
the concessions or the uh what what we
have done to prevail to address the
business of
the community so on the definition of
reasonableness
the uh dhhs had actually heard from
businesses
and the task force had heard from
businesses that they wanted an
actual definition of what was reasonable
so that's why we actually defined
in the bill what was reasonable and that
was based on the biology of a lactating
mother
so that was something that was asked for
businesses so they could have more
clarity so i just i wanted to
point that out and the other piece was
certainly they wanted to make this a
solution that worked for
new hampshire businesses in the unique
structure of new hampshire businesses so
many other states and 36 other states
have filled those gaps and have a
similar law
and they applied to all businesses but
hearing from the business community we
said okay
that doesn't make sense for new
hampshire we're going to raise that to
the congressional so we did that for
you know employers with six and above so
you know i think that just goes to show
that this bill has been worked and
worked and worked and certainly this
version of the bill reflects all of the
concerns brought to us by the business
community
so i just wanted you to be confident
that this bill is reflective of business
community
so it seems like we're kind of stuck
that's why i suggested that we recess
until tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock
and see if there's
wouldn't it be nice if you got half a
loaf rather than nothing
coming out of today would you rather
have nothing out for all these things
and you should i thought when we came
here we were open
right weren't we open then no i was
never i made a clear right yeah
i'm here to have give you guys a chance
to
express you know how important these
bills are but
excuse me i think i'm representing three
out of three people here
they would like to say that they could
say it's a good styles position
this is the house position and that you
know if it if it does it's unfortunate
and
that but that was your choice to put
these on you didn't come and
say gene you know hunt how do you think
your community is going to feel about it
if you stick these bills back
you know on this banking bill and i
would have told you then
that we're not tolerant
of you know because then determined like
an ominous bill but
that's all there's congress though but
no we yeah
we we you know
uh it's unfortunate um for the banking
department not to have this bill
uh 610 it does seem uh unfortunate you
know
strange that that you guys chose this
bill of all bills
to to load it up with non-german
amendments
and it seems unfortunate to us
introducing process
to underlying protections but here's
what i'm going to suggest
the way the process works now as you
know mr chairman
is that it's a household so you get the
write to look forward
you write the report any way you want we
would ask that you put
some or all of the four bills in that
report
then it will be our choice
if we're not going
[Music]
i'm asking you to reconsider your
position
and put in one two three or four
of those bills and then it will be our
choice whether we sign it
is that fair obviously yeah
okay what was the record obviously one
uh last year 12 34 had 77.
that was the last year two three four so
we need to reverse that trend all right
and you know what
i i agree with your representatives but
it makes it hard to
parse out the different issues right
because i think one case
i think these four issues are pretty
clear and it'd be one thing
we wouldn't be here if there was
significant opposition to any of them
wouldn't be here
so that's my suggestion if we're not
going to meet tomorrow it's at your
discretion as chair of the conference
committee prepare the report
in whatever way you're going to prepare
the report maybe our choice whether we
sign
maybe senator morris's choice whether he
replaces members
if he deems that appropriate or it'll
die
we don't know i'm pretty unhappy
to tell you the truth at you know what
i'm here
i'm a lot more unhappy right now than i
was when i walked in here at 10 o'clock
the kind of arguments that have been
used against killers pills so
that's my suggestion
6869 are not dead
they're certainly not going anywhere
right now mr chairman
my notes here says that your interim
study 638
6 38 is it my ingredients correct
that was last year oh that was flash
cheer so this time
it did pass from the same
[Music]
what happened to 638 638 when it came to
the house
senate bill 638 challenged the new
hampshire housing conservation planning
program
right that was last year has the house
ever heard this bill
no yes it was in senate bill um
i think the amendment stripped out the
section
part two of so the house position is
that they were not ready to pass this
bill that's correct and you're asking me
to pass
over mr disregard another client i'm
asking you to reconsider
your position of being opposed to
all four of the bills we're not going to
get everything this one's easy
okay we're not going to i accept that mr
chairman you're not going to give
us everything we want we're asking you
in particular
in the middle of a mental health crisis
and when pregnant or lactating mothers
need protection
to at least reconsider your position on
those bills
and maybe at a time that we need more
affordable housing
um i don't think there are any members
here from municipal county unless i'm
not you're all congress well maybe talk
to
you know the folks on municipal county
about the
part two piece of section 86 and
you know prepare your report hopefully
they'll there'll be a little bit more
flexibility than we're seeing right now
and then it'll be our choice when we
sign off
stand right here
you are unmuted
thank you we're resuming the committee
of conference on
household 417.
what are you trying to say
uh we also have the amendment that
i corrected after our discussion
yesterday
and um the house members have been
discussing this and if the
amendment does not have the
required affirmation continuation of the
state of emergency
we can't agree with that
please if you like
is
um
are you looking at it okay
[Music]
yes
uh
[Music]
um
cheers
the center back of the broadened
amendment
did we want to take that before we get
into intelligence
well that's the that's what i was
thinking about because
this has got a significant change but
i'm it doesn't appear to have
anything close to the house position
which is a
spoke to
that that's the health position and
although you know nice to have
constitutional language in this
constitution i don't believe that's
change that that's not
moving toward what the house position is
i mean the house has
instead of acquiring a approval every
every 30 days we've said okay the
governor have 90 days
before we have to vote this does not
require both of the legislature at any
point
just it just gives them the option which
is already
awesome it's a life it's nice it works
but i think it makes
sense
i can't i mean the redress of grievances
i mean i was here
back in 2010 at
you had a committee but i mean the
senate would have to change their rules
because we have no process for
redressing grievances
um so i don't even know how we didn't
begin to
formulate that um so i
thank you for trying to think a little
bit outside the box on this issue
senator
but i just see this making what is
already a
complicated issue even more complicated
and we wanted to try to be as
transparent as possible
with the public um so i just think that
this makes it a little more complicated
but thank you anyway
that's what and this was intended to be
a
fix the obvious errors and the currents
in the current statute which doesn't
allow
individual emergency orders to be
addressed and the
fiscal issues and we've got the fiscal
issues down
that's
[Music]
i think that the mandatory
i don't think
also it does certainly complicate things
which is not
awesome i just think that the compromise
that regarding offers
are already so far with the house passed
by
but the rest of it is the same we just
had to put everything
into an amendment that's all yeah no no
they uh
it's got section two it's still it's the
same at all
yeah it's uh affected c
c and r c and d right
so if you would like to have a vote we
will vote it down
[Music]
amendment in that case i'm going to move
the amendment
in 1999 each which
has a 30-day state of emergency
and then after 90 days the house the
governor
shall call a special session and press
us
reasons and then we have to continue the
scene
yes
did you come directly
oh
thank you very much
[Music]
making sure people sign up on stuff
thank you